let's say i've got some subspace of rn
let's say v is
a subspace
is a subspace of
r
n and let's say the set b
in blue let's say the set b
is a basis for v so it's got a bunch of
vectors in it let's say it's got v1
v2
all the way to
vk
so you can see we have k vector so v is
a k dimensional is a k dimensional
subspace
so that means
that means that if i have some
vector a let's say i have some vector a
that is a member of my subspace
that means that i can represent a as a
linear combination of these characters
right there so i could write a
as being equal to some constant times my
first basis vector
plus some other constant times my second
basis vector and then i could keep going
all the way to a k-th constant times my
k-th basis vector
now i've used the term coordinates
fairly loosely in the past and now we're
going to have a more precise definition
i am going to call
i am going to call these
these constants here i am going to call
these constants here so i am going to
call
c1 c2 all the way through
ck
i'm going to call them
the i'll do a new color
the coordinates
coordinates
coordinates of a
with respect
to
our basis b with respect to b and we
could also write it like this we could
also write
we could also write i have my vector a
so i have my vector a but if i wanted to
write my vector a with in coordinates
with respect to this basis set b i would
write it like this
put brackets around it and put the basis
set right there and this says i'm going
to write this in coordinates with
respect to this basis set
so
i will then write it like this i will
then write it like this i'm just going
to put
these weights there these constant terms
on the on the linear combination that i
have to get of my basis vectors to get a
so c1 c2
all the way to
ck
now there's one slightly interesting
thing or maybe very interesting thing to
point out here
v is a basis of rn so anything in v is
also going to be in rn but v has k
vectors has dimension k and that k could
be as high as n but it might be
something smaller maybe this is a you
know maybe we have two vectors in r3 in
which case
v would be a plane in r3 but we can
abstract that to further dimensions but
when you specify something that is in
our subspace with respect to its basis
notice you only have to have that many
the dimension of your of your subspaces
you only have to have that many
coordinates so even though a is a member
of rn i only had to give it k
coordinates because essentially you're
giving it positions within within let's
say if this was a plane within the plane
that is your subspace let me make this a
little bit a little bit more concrete
let me do some examples
so let's say we have some subspace let
me clear this out
let's say i have a couple of vectors
let's say
v1 is the vector
2 1
and let's say
v2
is the vector
1 2. now you might immediately see that
the basis
or the set
of v1 and v2
this is a basis for r2 this is a basis
for
r
2 which means that any
any vector in r2 can be represented as a
linear combination of these guys i could
do a visual argument or we also know
that look r2 is two dimensional
and we have two basis vectors right here
and they are linearly independent you
can verify that in fact the easiest way
to verify that is if you just take
2 1 and 1 2 and you put it in reduced
row echelon form you're going to get the
2 by 2 identity matrix
you're going to get
1 0 0 1 and that lets you know that this
guy
and this guy are both basis vectors so
that's all review we've seen that before
but let's visualize these let's
visualize these guys
so if i were to just graph it then the
way we normally graph these vectors what
does 2 1 look like let me draw some axes
here
let me draw it let me do a different
color
let me let's say that is my vertical
axis
and this is my horizontal axis
and 2 1 might look like this
so we're going to go out 1
2 and then we're going to go up 1.
so that is our vector 1 right there
that is 2 1 that's our vector 1 and then
one two
one two might look like or it does look
like this if i draw a standard position
one then we go up two
one two looks like this
so when we talk about coordinates with
respect to this basis let me pick some
other let me pick some member of r2 so
let's say let me just i'll engineer it
so that i i can easily find the linear
combination let me take
let me take
3 times
3 times v1
plus
plus 2 times
2 times v2 what is that going to be
equal to that's going to be equal to the
vector so 3 times two which is
six
plus two times one so it's the vector
eight
the vector eight and then i have the
vector three times v one plus two times
that so eight seven right three plus 2
times 2 is 4 8
7.
so if we were to just graph 8 7 in the
traditional way we would go 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 and then we would go up one
two three four five six seven and we
would have a vector i'm not gonna draw
it out here but it would specify
it would specify that point
right there that would be this point if
we if we view these as coordinates we
would view that as the point 8 7 right
there maybe i'll write it like that
that's the 0.87 if i wanted to draw this
vector in standard position i would draw
a vector that ends right there
now we have this basis here this basis b
represented by these two vectors this is
v 1 and v 2. what we want to do is
represent this guy let's say that i have
this vector let me call this vector
let me call that vector a so vector a
is equal to
8 7. now we know that if we wanted to
represent vector a as a linear
combination of my basis vectors it's
going to be 3 times v 1 plus 2 times v
2. so just given what we just saw in the
earlier part of this video we can write
that the vector a
the vector a
with respect to the basis b maybe i'll
do it in the same color as the basis
with respect to the basis b is equal to
these weights on the basis vectors is
equal to
and 2.
let's see if we can visually understand
why this makes sense we're saying we're
saying that in some new coordinate
system where this vector can be
represented as 3 2 and the way you think
about the new coordinate system is
in this old coordinate system we hashed
out ones in the horizontal axis and we
hashed out and that was our first
coordinate and we hashed out ones in the
vertical direction that was our second
coordinate now in our new in our new
system what's our first coordinate our
first coordinate is going to be
multiples
there's going to be multiples of v1 this
is v1 or this is v1 so it's multiples of
v1 so that's 1 times v1 then if we do 2
times v1 we're going to get over here 2
times v1 would get us to
what 2 would get us to 4 2
4 2 3 times v 1 would get us to 6 3 so
let's see 1 2
2 3 4 5 6 7 8. so 6
and then 3
just like that
and then 4 times v1 would get us to 8
and 4.
all right
so you can imagine that what i'm drawing
here this is kind of the axis the the
first term axis generated by v1 so i
could draw it let me do it in this blue
color so you could imagine it
could imagine it like this just be a
straight line
just like that
and then the coordinate tells me how
many v1s do i have so i would hash off
the coordinate system like this instead
of doing increments of one i'm going to
do increments of v1
increments of v1 right just like that as
you go 9 10 we're going to go up one
more to five something like that
right
now the second coordinate tells you
increments of v2
so this is our first increment of v2
then our second increment if we go to 4
it's going to be 4 2
just like that that's going to be 6
and 3.
it's going to be just like that and then
it's going to be
so 6 and 3 so it's going to look
something like this
so if you want to think of it as a bit
of a well you should be thinking of as a
coordinate system you can you can have
this new skewed graph paper where any
point you you can now specify it as
going in the v1 direction by some amount
and then by going in the v2 direction by
someone let me draw that as a bit of
graph paper so i could draw
i could draw
another version of v2 just like that
just
all the multiples of v2 i could shift
them like that i could do another one
like this
i could do another
that one is a little bit
not neat enough i could do it like that
i could do i think you're getting the
idea
like let me make that a little bit
neater
this might have been useful to do it
another tool and then i could do all the
multiples of v1 like this i'm doing a
graph paper right here so it looks
something like this
it would look something like this
and so you can imagine the skewed graph
paper if i did it all over the place
with this kind of green and this blue so
in our new coordinate system we're
saying three two so that means three
times our first direction which happens
to be the v1 direction it's no longer
the horizontal direction it's the v1
direction
so we go
we're going 1
and then we go 3
like that and then we're going to go 2
in the v2 direction so we're going to go
in the v2 direction and so our point is
going to be right there right you could
imagine going like this you go three in
the v1 direction and then you go one two
and the v2 direction you get to our
point or you could go kind of in your v2
direction and then your v1 direction but
either way you're going to get to your
original point so that vector or that
the the position specified by the vector
8 7 could just as easily be specified in
our new coordinate system
by the coordinates 3 2 because we're
saying 3 times v1 and then plus 3 times
v1 it takes us in this direction we're
going 3 notches in the v1 direction and
then we're going 2 notches in the v2
direction and so that's why these are
called that's why these are called
coordinates
coordinates you're literally saying how
many how many spaces in the v1 direction
to go and then how many spaces in the v2
direction to go but this might
this might i guess lead you to the
obvious question why have we been using
the coordinates before
like i might have been saying all along
i've been saying all along let's have
some vector
i don't know let's say i have some
vector lowercase b that is equal to
i don't know let's say it's equal to
i'll do it in r2 just because it's easy
to visualize let's say it's equal to
three
minus one
and if we you know if we were to graph
it
if we were to graph it it would look
something like this
we would go
1 2 3 and then we would go down 1.
so it would look something like this it
would specify this point but why have we
been calling 3 and negative 1
coordinates why have we been calling 3
and -1 coordinates we've been doing it
well before we learned linear algebra we
called these coordinates all the way
from when we first learned how to graph
why are we calling those coordinates
or how does this meaning of coordinates
relate to these coordinates with respect
to a basis well these are coordinates
with respect to bases these are actually
coordinates with respect to the standard
bases if you imagine let's see the
standard basis in r2 looks like this we
could have e1
which is
one zero
and we have e2 which is
zero one these are just this is just the
convention for the standard basis in r2
and so we could say if we call
let's say s is equal to the set of e1
and e2
then we say that s is
the standard
standard
basis basis
for
r2 and it's the standard basis because
these two guys are orthogonal they're
just this is one in the horizontal
direction this is one in the vertical
direction and any vector
any vector in r2 let's say i have some
vector
let's say i have some vector
x
y in r2 it's going to be equal to x
times
e 1
plus
y times y times
e2 so we could say that if you want to
write
if you want to write some vector
x y
if you wanted to write it with respect
to this standard basis right here
with respect to the standard basis
so i'm going to write it with respect to
the standard basis it's going to be
equal to the coordinates by the
definition that we did earlier in this
video of the basis vectors right there
are these weights on our e1's and e2 so
it's going to be equal to well the
weight there is x
and the weight here is y
so these coordinates that we've been
talking about from the get go these are
definitely coordinates they're
consistent with our definition of
coordinates in this video but we can
maybe be a little bit more precise we
can now call them the coordinates
coordinates
with
respect
with respect to the standard basis
standard
with respect to the standard basis or we
could call them we could call these
right here we could call these the
standard
coordinates standard coordinates i just
wanted to point this out this might be
almost trivially simple or a bit obvious
but i just want to show that our old
usage of the words coordinates was not
inconsistent with this new definition of
coordinates as being the weights as
being the weights on some some basis
vectors because even in our old
coordinates or the old way we use them
these really were weights on our
standard basis vectors